Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Cutters, sharing with you some of my favorite things to use for different disorders from a natural perspective.
Today we're going to talk about turmeric, or the active ingredient in it is curcumin.
If you have other questions, make sure you visit our clinic, the website's on that slide, cuttersclidic.com
And make sure you download my book. I talk a lot about this and a whole bunch of other things in my book.
And it's a free download. So if you go on a clinic website, or you click the little icon on the right side of the video and the top right side of the video, you can download my book for free.
The icon will take you to our website and you'll see where the download is.
And what we did with the book is we turned it into a course. So not only will you, you will just have this gigantic PDF of 350 pages that you got to read through.
But you get some videos similar to this to kind of precede the chapter and then you get the chapter. So it kind of breaks it into a course that makes it a little easier to digest and easier to understand to get it over the course of about a month.
So hopefully, you know, there's a lot of information. You know, you got cancer, you're loved one as cancer, you're searching for things to do it because extremely confusing.
We're just trying to take that out of the equation.
So to Rick or curcumin, whatever you want to use to describe it is a spice from India.
Grown up, it's very orange.
That's probably the worst thing about to Rick is its color because it can stain your clothes.
So if you're going to use it as a topical with in a topical cream, which we do with a lot of patients, we create our own topical sams.
And we use curcumin a lot with that is it's very staining. So you have to put something over in a big bandage, cover it up somehow or it'll stain all your clothes and you'll never get them unstained.
I mean, it's done. So using it even in cooking and stuff, you have to be careful.
It should spill it on your clothes or spilled somewhere where you'll track it around the house and you will not be happy.
But it is a fantastic tool to help with all sorts of cancers. It literally blocks basically every cancer it helps with.
So you cannot really go wrong with turmeric. You just cannot.
It's just that's almost impossible to overdose on it.
And it decreases the inflammatory process without decreasing the immune system.
That's a huge piece of turmeric.
For the medical approach to decrease in inflammatory processes, basically using something like predisone, which will basically shut down the TH1 side of the immune system.
Well, you need that TH1 side of the immune system to prevent cancer. That's why long term use of predisone greatly increases your risk for cancer because if you don't have an immune response, you're never going to be able to help with the apoptonic process to kill cancer cells.
So cancer can start because of an immune suppression.
Well, turmeric decreases the inflammation, also helps increase apoptotic cycles, which is the normal program cell death. So it increases cell death and decreases inflammation without decreasing it immune response.
So it just works fantastic. Matter of fact, studies have shown that it works on so many stages of cancer's progression, so many pieces of it overexpressant.
That centerpiece, it says overexpressant of oncogenes, which are genes that push cancer along her two positive genes, which are estrogen receptive cancer.
So breast cancers, uterine cancers, a lot of the hormonally driven cancers, turmeric is just so beautiful for.
So you cannot go wrong again with adding turmeric.
Turmeric also decreases the adhesion factors.
So metastatic tumors are started by circulating tuber cells that break off the primary tumor site and do exactly what their name is.
They circulate through their body, through your body looking for a place to set up home and start a family per se.
Now, there's some adhesion molecules that have to take place for that circulated tuber cell to stop and adhere and start to grow and start to go into rapid replication phase and thereby be cancer at that site.
And then it would be a metastatic cancer.
Well, turmeric does fantastic things to break those adhesion factors, so not allowing circulating tuber cells to do what they want to do.
That is, dark cancer somewhere else in the body.
So using turmeric is super, super important to always understand too.
If you're doing chemotherapy or radiation, there's no reason why you cannot do turmeric or curcumin.
So even if your oncologist says you cannot be doing any herbs or anything else, do your own studies because he doesn't know what he's talking about.
So turmeric and curcumin are something that you should be adding to your protocol, talk about dosage in just a second.
Turmeric helps block this tumor progression in every stage of its progression in initiation, tumor promotion, tumor cell survival and proliferation, which is rapid replication.
Curcumin helps break that.
And geogenesis decreases in geogenesis by tumor cells.
And geogenesis is when a tumor increases a laid out of new blood vessels.
So angiogenesis is the creation of new blood vessels into a tumor so that that tumor can be fed and the tumor can grow more rapidly.
So what angiogenesis into a tumor will curcumin helps decrease that.
And like I said, it breaks adhesion molecules so it decreases your chance of metastasis.
So this slide talks about where other things that will decrease in inflammatory response can decrease in immune response,
turmeric, decreases in inflammatory response at different levels.
So it doesn't decrease the immune response that you need so desperately with cancer cells, going to what I just talked about before.
Turmeric curcumin is also very multi-targeted.
It works on so many different levels, so many different areas.
This slide alone we can spend a couple hours on because it just works on everything you want it to work on.
In my book I talk about a 10 step protocol that you want to bring to your doctor if you have cancer,
and make sure that you solve these 10 steps.
Well, curcumin really solves many of those 10 steps.
So it's a huge player and something that is good to add to cancer.
It's not just for cancer either.
So turmeric is very good for brain inflammation.
We use it on any Alzheimer's, dementia patients.
You'll also use it on traumatic brain injury.
It's a huge player in decreasing brain inflammation helping heal the blood brain barrier.
Helping heal the vascular area.
Helping heal inflammation in the ethereal layer.
So that has to do with heart disease.
It has strokes.
Any heart blockages or vascular blockages.
Turmeric is a great player in that.
Helps decrease blood sugar.
It's an immune booster.
Helps with weight loss, wound healing, and so many things.
It's a great player.
So how do you get turmeric?
Well, you can take it with a capsule like this.
Now this is a design for health product.
There's some other really good products out there too, so I'm not just pushing this company.
But turmeric needs to be, here's two rules for taking turmeric.
You need to take it with a fat.
It's also good to add a little black pepper with it.
That is important to add black pepper with turmeric as it is to add black pepper with respiratory.
But it still helps preserve the half-life of the product once it's in your bloodstream.
But absolutely when you take turmeric you need to take it with a fat.
That is the most important thing.
In fact, there were several studies a decade or so ago that talked about turmeric as being so effective
that they did a study using turmeric powder on a different group of people.
And they didn't get the same results until they found out that the first group of people that they did the studies with were eating a fatty diet
and were taking the turmeric when they were eating the food.
And the second group of people were taking the turmeric on an empty stomach.
And neither one of these products actually were emulsified in a fat.
You need to have the turmeric emulsified in a fat.
Or if you're going to just take powdered turmeric, you need to take it with a fat.
So there's multiple ways to get turmeric in your body then.
Number one is sprinkling on your food.
So if you're sprinkling on your food there's fat in your food.
It has to be a fatty food so you can't sprinkle it on broccoli.
You'll think you're going to get a good dose of absorption there.
Unless the broccoli has been sauteed in coconut oil.
So you need to sprinkle it on a fatty food and take it that way.
That's a good way to do it, but some people don't like the taste.
So, well, I don't want to take it with food.
I don't like the taste of turmeric.
It's spicy. It's got that Indian flavor.
It's not really hot spicy, but it's got that Indian flavor.
It's not people don't like it. I love it, but some people don't.
So second way to take it, you can go buy bulk turmeric in your health food store,
get organic bulk turmeric, and you can just take it orally.
Again, you're tasty that.
But you have to take it with a fat.
So you chase it with coconut oil.
So you take a teaspoon of powdered turmeric, chase it with some water,
take a tablespoon of coconut oil, and chase it with that too.
You need a fat in your gut when you take it.
Take it right around the fatty food.
So, gulp down a teaspoon of turmeric right after you ate a fatty food
like a regular meal with some fat in it.
That's the second way to get it in.
Or you take it in a product that is already pre-emulsified.
This curcumin, this C3 curcumin of designs for health is already pre-emulsified
in an organic cold pressed sunflower oil.
So, you don't have to worry about that.
It's when, and with my patients, when I want them to take turmeric,
I want them to have them take maybe a capsule of this every two hours
or even a capsule of this every hour of their waky day.
It's really hard to be taken that much coconut oil
and you don't have food in your stomach throughout the whole day.
So, sometimes it's best to get it in a capsule form like this.
That's already pre-emulsified in a fat.
Does that make sense to you?
So, if you have to rewind this a little bit and listen to that again,
you have to do that.
Now, a dosage typically like this with the capsules
anywhere between 300 and 500 milligrams.
This particular product, I believe, is 400 milligrams.
Now, you want to take, what type of cancer you have,
you want to take upwards of three to even eight grams.
There's 1,000 milligrams in a gram.
So, this is where I have a person maybe take one of these an hour
during their waky day, especially if they have a colon cancer
or something like that.
It's very, very good for that.
Multiple by a little bit responds really well to curcumin as well.
Really, you go back to the early slides, almost every cancer does.
So, it's just super beneficial for you.
So, those are some different ways to get to know this slide just talks about that
bulk turmeric with cooking.
But make sure it's at a fatty food.
So, you can even sprinkle it on your broccoli as well.
You just saute it in coconut oil.
Hopefully, that will be helpful for you.
There's just tons of studies on turmeric out there.
I tell you, it's very populous studies in,
if you want a Google Scholar, search some of the curcumin studies out there.
It's really, really all positive, just fantastic.
So, I hope this was beneficial.
If you have any other questions, just check out our website,
there's clinic.com, or feel free to call us and to set up a consultation appointment if you need so.
All right, bye-bye.